talk this is live at the All Things
comedy studio and it is brought to you
by my incredible sponsor earthquaker
devices you play guitar bass PP boards
you play p boards people keyboards like
whatever you play get some [ __ ] stomp
boxes out of Akron Ohio handmade heavy
metal machines soul vibe get something
get the dell ranger pedal hit him up
earthquaker devices calm farm on twitter
what's going on Michael Devon is here
today what is happening Dean Del Rey the
return of Michael Devon we're gonna be a
couple of regulars here man it's like
mark and Brian yeah yeah our [ __ ]
yeah all right man get home with you
thanks for joining me today oh thanks
for having me here today here we go I'm
good yeah man you walked in and you said
you were you've been getting some my
acupuncture which I have mitch is a
great topic today because I went my
first time on saturday uh was this your
first time going no but it's actually my
it's my first time going in life yes but
it's not my first appointment no i I've
been to him now like twice but he wants
to see me again this week man yeah I
wonder about that too me too money she
put the needles in my neck and then went
I see or three times a week okay yeah
wait a minute here did it now what are
you going for you got some hand problems
or something no I actually got a I got a
foot condition oh it's going numb um no
I have this old injury man and the and
the ankle is locked so my toe is kind of
always kind of sticking up which toe my
pic Tober really yeah it's crazy it's
just I broke it in a real bad at a real
bad time I broke it Wow car crash no I
was hopping a fence huh yeah and in the
sounds like you're bullshitting now
hoppiness yeah
just can't get into it too deep okay I
was hopping a fence yet and slap you got
it you got to be honest until it had it
I just had Carl above on and yesterday's
episode and this guy dropped some of the
most honest stories I've ever heard of
human say on a [ __ ] mic really and
man the reactions the people oh boy they
are just loving this episode they are
yeah you know who he was Sam Kinison
children they started together and what
a radical story this man I saw its been
blowing up yeah asking you way out of
putting it up and I mean yeah it's great
that's so what happened that foot you
want to no idea I was running yeah yeah
please not a bad story now not a bad
storm Austin are here uh here yes yeah
racing well within well no the injury is
actually quite old uh-huh but I never
did anything for it i never got any any
PT or anything like that I I got a cast
you know it like the clinic yeah he came
in with like you know a bowl of old
soupy you know plaster of Paris all that
old [ __ ] and just kind of right and then
when I got it taken off see I'm a man
who walks around on this plan without
insurance me too so this is me too it's
[ __ ] it's absolutely haunting me now
yeah up to yourself hanta see but when
you're 30 or 25 you like yeah you're
bulletproof yeah and so you don't even
care if you die at that time yeah yeah
25 yeah yeah good weight good time to go
ahead fast yeah yeah yeah good core yeah
especially in rock and roll all your
heroes yeah are dead be worth yeah most
of the time yeah I mean but I don't want
to die now neither do i it's taking me a
long time to get there well I don't want
to die now but there was a time in my
life when I really did want to die
really oh yeah yeah I was crazy I was
crazy duh yeah like Priya California you
mean back in Boston like you don't know
yeah [ __ ] you doing yeah when I was uh I
was living in Boston
alone in a studio apartment i was
getting i was going to college i was
getting out getting the got dark getting
my graduate degree yeah and yeah got
dark it was really [ __ ] dark there
man what was it I've never wanted myself
it was to passion and it was uh it was
uh probably just some some old uh uh i
think i was diagnosed with PTSD we're
really gonna get into the [ __ ] yeah
absolutely um I was diagnosed I think
when I was younger maybe even though I
still have it on over with PTSD what's
that that is post-traumatic stress
disorder right like the the step the
soldiers come back yeah okay what was
your stress from something that happened
in life uh yeah when I was when I was a
kid I I think I was about 14 I went into
this I was admitted into this family
treatment center is what it was called
was called straight straight
incorporated yeah my parents I you know
I was I was sort of a never do well and
you know smoking a lot of dope and yeah
listen to a lot of rock and roll and
just not really given a [ __ ] right
except for music yep but um my parents
decided that it was best to put me into
this place you know god bless their
hearts I don't they didn't know really
what was happening behind the walls but
yeah it was a it was a pretty crazy
place they use the same tactics on us
mentally oh you told me about as they do
my prisoners of war yeah it's like it's
like the place that was like brutalized
yeah they strip your they strip your
identity your ego everything they strip
you down and then they kind of rebuild
you into what they consider to be a
model citizen everything from your
vocabulary I got another everything kind
of like a full military but but almost
in a cult II way it is more of a cult
than a military because even in the
middle even if it were militant like a
outward bound or something they'd have
you running they'd have you moving we we
had we had fluorescent tans yeah we
never left the building Wow we were in
there for like you know whatever 15 18
hours a day listening to this to this
propaganda and his rhetoric and it was
all built under under the reagan-bush
yeah I remember you telling me about
campaign that whole Nancy Reagan just
say no campaign when they had Webster on
TV
you know that was a that was all you
know with this little just say no and go
and tell someone you trust that whole
thing yeah yeah that was all little did
we know they were like teeth yeah it's
crazy right yeah but you know man I am I
made it out of me through and you know
so you got some depression from
flashbacks of that yeah for a long time
man I couldn't you know I couldn't take
[ __ ] literally without having some kind
of a of a flashback because I couldn't
in that place you can't go to the
bathroom alone someone to watch you yeah
another your peers it's a little bit
like Lord of the Flies it's like yeah
it's it's it's run by adults but it's
monitored and controlled by your peers
Wow so another fellow boy would be the
door to the stall essentially that I'm
you know going crazy [ __ ] how long were
you in there three years no I broke out
I made to attest right I made two
attempts to break out and the first
attempt was not a success because and I
was so close man oh i was so close but
you know i was i was running to my
parent's car cuz they pulled up to where
I was hiding now you know your parents
couldn't even get you out they could
they could sign me up but they were they
were brain you know there was a
brainwashing going on yeah hey whatever
he says isn't true yeah I got a
babysitter and she'd hit you with these
hot wheel tracks yeah I tell her mom
amen this [ __ ] crazy ladies hit me
with hot wheel tracks it took a couple
weeks before she caught me out cuz I
later back he's got a big imagination
right Shanet sucker you whip us man hot
wheel track I still [ __ ] in Wow oh
yeah yeah now yeah that'll smart yeah
over dumb stuff yeah yeah I mean I think
people are just I think there's that
inclination to hit yeah anyway so yeah
this is anything gold fat woman you know
and crazy here yeah man you know it's uh
I had some of this uh PTSD you know like
after the motorcycle crash you know yeah
it's funny because you're talking about
acupuncture
sure and now here I am it's been like 7
months after the crash or something I
don't know September seventh I'm walking
around like I'm fine and in the last few
weeks my neck just starts locking up man
like and it's in I went to the doctor
goes yeah dude you went down at [ __ ]
you got hit by someone at 70 miles an
hour sure you're still like you you know
your shoulder might be a little sore but
other shits going to come out from that
absolutely like I was having some
internal pains and it goes yeah your
shits all [ __ ] joggle do you not have
broke ribs and stuff so I'm tired of
going to the doctor and they say the
same [ __ ] here this take some aleve
right yeah that's all they ever say and
it's the famous Louie bit I think it's
one of my favorite Louie bits of all
time Louie CK but when he goes he goes
yeah my ankles [ __ ] and the guy goes
yeah you're just gonna have to take a
leave but it's how long is your not
forever it is always that bad for your
gut he's like yeah well you either you
have a bad gut or a bad ankle you choose
yeah and he's like wait what if I was an
athlete their knees like you're not an
ass it's one of the funniest yes I've
ever hurt here because I totally I'm 50
now and I start relating like everything
just [ __ ] hurts and 50 is so young
yeah I there's a guy in my building i
think it's 92 yeah cruises out ultime
dean what's up it gets on a bike he
rides to ralphs he gets [ __ ] he's always
walking around he's [ __ ] on it you
know 92 years old old school old school
road [ __ ] for rockford files and [ __ ]
my favorite Yeah right this guy's old
school um you know back then man meat
was different me he had most of his life
yeah being normal that's what I say that
people that live old now the eighth
grade [ __ ] for about 30 years yea or no
like 50 years yeah and now they're
eating the [ __ ] for the last thirty here
well that's not gonna kill them because
they'll be like I mean it's going to
kill them but
they'll already be dead for mother ship
right on a cellular level they're still
right there still good and but with us
now with whit [ __ ] we're [ __ ] its food
the cell phone Reuters the water weed
your honor we're drinking plastic it
yeah yep and oh yeah man all this yeah
all these signals as we sleep man I
started looking around my house and
thinking whatever you just get rid of
everything and I set my records and my
leather jacket so analog only analog
yeah mi mi bike yeah and then when you
die there's no work for your friends you
just like get out hey he's got sick side
of the SICU wats up yeah and there's
names on em yeah Jim this is yours
everybody's gonna want those records
yeah if I could do yeah it's an easy
thing totally have an empty house yeah
wrap up and then if you don't ever die
you've got a complete I don't know
anything it's great yes it's a dark
morbid thing but you know yeah it's a
[ __ ] cool idea yes it is because we
accrue a lot of [ __ ] in our lifetimes
don't women oh god so much man I want
[ __ ] I don't want [ __ ] either I said I
want checking in of just get [ __ ] the
wonderful thing about moving a lot
though getting rid of [ __ ] yeah and I've
done it a lot in los angeles man you
just get rid of [ __ ] used to hold on to
so dearly i can't get rid of this you
know first edition of great expectations
accepted by your fifth move you like
handing it over to the old lady next
door you like great expectation there
you go happy so you're going my first
time like acupuncture yeah saturday yeah
interesting thing yep lady was great
that I went to Steve Agee turned me on
to this up lady yeah family has been
doing it for a hundred years damn yeah
so I go and see aha hey you Steve why
you sis yeah so no no move so she puts
me on the long hard kind of doctor bed
yeah and hang my neck and arms off the
back yeah for 15 or for sorry five
minutes we gotta call you got here to
stir let's grab the call hey what's
going on you're on the air who's calling
in
oh it's an ottoman cold from the UK all
right what's happening the UK which
happened mother okay I'm the star with
the record store sent your message oh
you got the record store yeah record
store on the record label and put on
live shows oh forget in what part of the
UK are you um some places Brian drunky
wow so uh-- newcastle yeah that's a good
rowdy town right there Newcastle yeah I
mean it's not as awkward you speaking
about what Sheffield oh yeah I'm quite a
bit it's not as bad as them yellow
Sheffield's Detroit of the UK say thanks
Steel City you know yeah Newcastle's got
a good night life though man there's
some nice bars and restaurateur and then
basically was because I'm obviously you
live i knows came up over the last you
know the loss and after the last couple
of sure that is being across so many
different park a separate the chair
George is for a lot obviously to make in
such a huge combat in it then you were
talking about it i think with last week
or the week before and you're mentioning
you know things that we are also very
and those kind of things and how it
affects and still like in a good or bad
way i was told i was so i was talking
about how record stores were saying that
the record companies are just going for
the evil route again so they figured out
the people aren't records so now the
wholesale arm to the record stores
through the roof and then the retail has
to be thirty dollars for a [ __ ]
record you know well basically not a
permit from a record label point of view
and like hardened available for the one
that got now and could be
some sort of ties in with the store
which is why Allah created a new one and
put the previous one was going to first
thought about it was about six radical
and then it was about a month waiting
time to short the rebel press yep and
there is now you're looking at roughly
six month German and that's because
basically the major labels are just
passing out like everything in the park
while all the other flooding there's
only about now I I don't know if this is
true but I've started researching it
because a friend of mine a comedian
wants to get his record pressed he asked
me to help them and I realized there's
only like six plants that cut vinyl
right now is that right like major
plants well you know when CDs Palin and
obviously vinyl sort of like everybody
was kind of off finally straight on the
three days and I know about the UK
showed all of their repressive equipment
to the Czech Republic well so now
revival press most of it that's personal
czech republic and then the people in
the UK are just like them middleman so
essentially no matter which company you
rim but getting the record from the
sensation that that is they're always
like they're like middle men so that
they just make a phone call and so that
it forwarded to you so it looks like
you're using a company but they're
actually using the same press but
they're like hey we press final really
pressed vinyl put apparently only i was
reading about a month or so ago the bony
just got somebody and who's actually
starting to roommate the machines right
and so I mean hope the thing is i mean
it is still a good friend even if the
major labels are also getting really
under it and for the prices for record
store they're like it basically when let
me get let alone say surprise mommy so
right well you'll get like okay please
the 25-percent this form roughly and
where is on record store day okay like
repair price wholesale level and then so
you could be caught I mean similar
prices and it's hard for surgery
obviously with dollars and pounds it was
different over here right and some of
the prices over here were crazy and I
know that we are gonna you know American
and basic you have you are as well yeah
I was like you know you're going to
let's say there was a record that I
wanted it was record store day and brand
new is $45 yeah for a [ __ ] record you
know and it's like that's obscene how
much and not only that but the material
was record it was a live record and the
interior was recorded 40 years ago
there's zero zero cost in this it wasn't
like a band went into the studio tracked
a record for a year at the record plant
at twenty-five hundred a day with a
producer text and [ __ ] food and
lodging it was none of that it was a
live recording from 1972 and and and
basically they just sent that and then
got some art work together and it was
$45 the way I look at that it was like a
forty dollar profit yeah well that's
what he was just saying is that yeah all
the labels are going into their back
catalogue yeah there's zero issuing yeah
and in checking them when they reissue
it they've already owned the Masters
yeah they're not remastered yeah yeah
onew any now they are starting to
because they were getting so much [ __ ]
but if they even very much oh what's
that what was interesting was that you
know how I was saying that obviously was
a six-month sort of waiting time for our
person yeah when Prince Kai yeah they
sent an email with following day with a
list of
repressive that with juin in a month's
time so i was like thinking to myself
wait a minute help him if I could talk
about them and say I've got a record
that I want to get press and I've got
the money to party and you've gotta pay
up from so it means you've essentially
got six months while you've got lettin
off and absorbed and then but anyway you
got to pay six months in advance when
you've got a place like in full up front
before you go it used to be happy to
serve yeah well then because the leak
and have got longer for whatever like
for whatever reason now you've got a
pelean anti-romantic fun and I mean if
you get a record repast as well provide
them oh you know like the play too okay
yeah the cost drops like dramatically
because because that's what the most
expensive part of it is is to get like
the play tonight yeah and even if you
even if you've ever played really maybe
still looking at a couple of months now
Brooklyn like a favor and print side
when David Bowie guys when let me down
and straight away it was like you know
all of the repressors from the major
labels trying to sort of Lebanon it as
quickly as possible instantly done
because they just said hey here's some
extra money precious to the front of the
line yeah well it also has to do with
like hey this guy's pressing 1500
records we need 500,000 just skip that
project for now yeah yeah I know about
the bigger the biggest hold of us humans
with the last level was when the old
caramel with you know the mono and
stereo voxer no got pushed back almost
everybody and I mean that as a couple of
friends of mine available and I think
even some of their and labels are still
a bit smell about like you know like i
would say an indie label like relapse
and your leggings and labor for that and
very even recording
stop mass would be impulse bought and it
was all because the deal [ __ ] sex with
her ease of you and talking problem
what's crazy to me to think about that
it's like Radiohead just came out the
new record on Sunday which means which
means that they probably recorded that
over a year ago and to get it start
getting it ready to get pressed and [ __ ]
yeah yeah any means well so I was just
going to say I just cooked the cook like
our order in for that are one final yep
and it was I think and Juna july for the
release stated virtual vinyl so I mean
that they've still obviously got so you
know some of the time to white right the
cds pretty if I wanted to see teammates
I would wait maybe a week yeah are you
gonna see me I could get a CD made at a
guy's house hell we could do that for
you right now it's so funny you could
just go to the valley they got these
[ __ ] places that have these seven
million machines and they just put the
glass master in and they gotta see you
tomorrow and they're done overnight
overnight [ __ ] crazy I got a buddy
who owned something he owns one of those
machines yeah like CD babe yeah at the
time when I was playing music I owned a
ten burner yeah and it was that way I'd
go on the road I had all the artwork
already and boxes and boxes in my garage
and I just blast up 10 and then just
wheel on the [ __ ] there was like an
art word sticker yeah there's a machine
just pressed onto the sticker I mean ass
and then [ __ ] man I made thousands from
my own [ __ ] [ __ ] out of your duffle
bag yeah it was great man you know we
used to be on like bad pipes and I
suggest certain it was the cook for air
like age of maybe four hours our code on
tape real time before
yeah man in real time any one of those
days I know a few bands and I won't say
who they are but they're genius they got
ripped off from the record companies of
course so when they go out on tour now
the cds you're buying are the ones they
made at home that look exactly the ones
because they're not making any money
from the record so they boot like this
rainiers 10 years yeah yeah they don't
even know who to [ __ ] ask you the
money anymore you know they're like oh I
nover am NOT insane because we were
really public of oil and the suppliers I
don't think whether the disturb I think
they were supplier who release records
as well and but it's one of the surprise
i use not actually where that this rel
author was a record store their
exclusive and it was from jack off jill
here in the they they publicly said
goodbye because we haven't had any money
from our label for entirety but this
being hard on our that's what the Martha
did too there's a label called music for
music for nations or whatever and they
just pretty print up vinyl through a
deal with capital and they're getting no
money so said don't buy those and and so
I didn't buy it seems that comes up a
lot and it's one of those things that's
so common now yeah totally just run out
the ROM DRS hey thanks for coming in man
I appreciated it and and really cool to
talk to you man open thank you see ya
take it easy cool guy he he emails me
quite a bit he listens to the show over
there yeah and owns his own record store
and label in D shines bands hit he
believes in and stuff and cool dude
wants to sponsor the podcast he's way
into the [ __ ] that's cool yeah really
good dude right so it's cool to hear
from them yeah anyway yeah man so you
doing a record right now let's get back
to the occupation yeah or we do that's a
good heads up
cuz you're gonna want to press at the
vinyl it's the only thing people buy
yeah i know what i was talking to the
label who is interested right now about
that oh yeah yeah and they said they've
done it for a few bands but as this
gentleman was was talking about man I'm
very very very skeptical of getting into
business with people especially it's
your artwork yeah you know you put all
this time and all this sweat tears all
the whole thing into this thing and then
somebody gives you the phils you full of
hope and promises and then just sticks
the [ __ ] thing on a shelf yeah
there's no that sucks there's nothing
there's nothing going to come from it
anymore you gotta be like a ty Segall or
whatever and you just put out [ __ ]
non-stop prom yeah and and just enjoy
what you're doing and just play gigs and
play with different dudes all the time
and [ __ ] and just the moral coals
irons in the fire you know the more
you're gonna be playing yeah let's get
this call what's going on you're on the
air hey what's up Dean who's calling man
where he called from ah this is nick and
i'm in houston oh [ __ ] man i just had a
car on yesterday did you hear that
Houston Carl above from Houston he was
one of the original out laws of comedy
him Kennison Bill Hicks yeah actually
listen to the whole thing today it was
entertaining was a good father yet that
was beyond entertaining man it was just
like this guy's he sat on my couch what
a great man I mean he's alive I think
most people 99% of people would shoot
their self after one of the things that
happened to him yeah you know right what
a strong strong man I love it what's
going on do you know what what on that I
was just going to say you know other
than yours I listen to love it a few
other comedians podcast and and you know
I'm 36 so I don't I wasn't in the whole
time with Kennison and Hicks but uh you
know I here on other podcast oh yeah I
remember when he [ __ ] that dudes wife
and it wasn't his kid yeah you know I I
never knew who y'all were talking about
i just didn't take the time to look it
up so I'm listening out
podcasting like oh [ __ ] that's yeah I
gotta listen to this but it's pretty
pretty amazing because even as I was
interviewing him I had forgotten a story
because I was such a I was such a huge
Sam Kinison fan early forever but early
in my comedy career I started hearing
this name Carl above and I didn't know
who he was because I was young when
Kennison was big and and high a high a
lot and drunk so to me it was just Sam
yeah yeah yeahs little screaming a lot
of that don't see the opening band don't
see the opening comic don't see anything
opening stay outside and get high you
know yeah um yeah good fallback I feel
I've never seen Kennison on married with
children oh wow yeah I don't want to see
bad guy and he's like no son uh-huh but
as he was on the couch and he said he
told me the story I was like wow though
the main thing about that is he proved
it wasn't his kid and they were still
trying to get him to pay child support I
want to [ __ ] him I want to [ __ ] go
crazy when I hear that [ __ ] they took
his passport and his driver's license
because he wasn't paying child support
on a kid proven that wasn't his what
what the [ __ ] are you talking about he's
as awesome it's just the system man it's
just stay was he living in California
man get the [ __ ] just [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know i'm in texas and i haven't I've
never been divorced but from friends of
mine and aunts and uncles like they
don't play around here too it's all it's
all in the woman's favor and and you
know once that rulings done there that's
it and well here's the thing and I and I
and I love women and I don't women
Bashan and I don't man bash it or
anything I system bash because this this
stuff was put in place in what 20s 30s
40s when the woman stayed home was a
housewife had no skills I get it you
know or income or income that's not me
it's so when the when the when the they
divorced
they would just be in a world of
complete fear what do I do okay I get
that but in this world of the man works
and the woman works and and and then you
get divorced and you're giving alimony
checks to a woman while she's out
sleeping with other dudes that's [ __ ]
that is a wrong wrong system she's
working a job she's she's uh you know
supporting herself no problem and you're
sending checks while she's in Malibu
taking selfies with the dude it's just
crazy but it's big business and it's a
big especially in the state wherein in
California right big business divorce I
saw a great documentary on earth now
divorce incorporated I believe it was
called yeah Wow and in all of the
divorce attorneys who go out there and I
mean they it's it's their job to rouse
you know whomever it is either is the
woman or the man but usually they get
there the closet into a woman who's
probably really distraught you know it's
it's an unnatural act whether you want
to consider not mean to break up for
nucleus to break up you know I mean it's
like you're it's unnatural but it
happens and it happens a lot but these
guys step in you know let's say that and
they start squirting fire that's the
thing it's like you may have you may
have some kind of like pre-arranged
agreement with your your soon-to-be ex
right like hey you know what i'm gonna
i'm leaving with this you're leaving
with that and we're all good they come
in and they start sniffing around for
your dirt the nail right and next thing
you know they've got her thinking oh
you're right i am entitled to this and i
am entitled to that and i am entitled to
this but a lot of times it's not out of
vindictiveness or malice it's just out
of fear and in uncertainty to and when
you can reassure somebody with a
financial promise yeah you know in in a
world where there's no certainty because
divorce it's a [ __ ] crazy time it's
like what's going to happen to me what's
going to happen to my kid where am I
we're going to end up yeah if you can
assure we're ensure that there's going
to be some bread
there then they're gonna follow that
whether it's reluctantly or not I get
that is the [ __ ] huge problem with
the system I get it but if the person
has a [ __ ] job and I'm not talking
child support at all like one hundred
percent you must pay child support yeah
don't be a [ __ ] idiot get two jobs
whatever you have a human being don't be
a [ __ ] deadbeat yeah absolutely but
if there's no [ __ ] kids involved and
you're married okay once you get to 10
years in California you must pay her the
rest of your life alamo until she gets
married again which is mind [ __ ]
boggling so you can get married again
find love and happiness and still be
paying this ex-wife yeah and now it's in
through the system so you don't even
have the luxury of your ex-wife saying
hey you know what don't pay me any more
I'm good now it goes into the system and
then they pay her it's insane so if you
don't pay they come and arrest your ass
and or they just take it right out of
your bank right now right it's
unbelievable you know it's a sham anyway
thanks for calling in dude such good
times good copy yeah yeah hey go you
don't know yep your buddy is a bass
player there I also play bait oh good
now you know play space and white snake
right oh yeah yeah okay I I saw the
Instagram and I've heard him before so
it's all good digging me what know what
kind of kind of been a [ __ ] about what
about 15 years ago I bought a 1976
Rickenbacker during 4001 yes no no
active pickups in that thing just
straight plug in and I've never even
looked at another face since that man
nothing so so versatile and so beautiful
I just I love it oh do I've got a
Rickenbacker it's got a 78 same thing
it's the best club level trans double
tressure it's all about the double truss
rod in that basement that thing will
never you could you could
jim on a on a glacier and that thing
will still stay in to me yeah no [ __ ]
weather channel nothing man no neck band
it's a beautiful beautiful piece what a
great instrument could burden paul
mccartney's our Butler either but he
played one yeah he did for a little
while during that the never-say-die
arrow I love that he had a remote you
know they found us Tim thank God
everything everybody thanks man all
right thanks dude yeah handles late did
keep playing bro yeah Ozzie they found
him that's gonna be a divorce a good
money one that's an interesting thing
because I don't know what happened and
I'm not gonna I'm not going to assume or
whatever yeah there's a few different
things in there that i always think and
it was funny i was with a woman last
night friend and we were talking and
she's like it's like the old bill burr
bit the King gets more women than
regular people yeah yeah I mean you
marry a musician yeah you you're
marrying a lunatic yeah at what point do
you think and I'm thinking this is over
yeah 33 years or whatever their sandy
yeah allegedly slept with the
hairdresser the other hairdresser right
you know it's just kind of like it was
only once you know what I mean like
there was nothing in the 80s out when
he's out with [ __ ] Randi Rousseau you
know those rumors right he's didn't she
actually she's gonna swimming around
mitad it yeah slept with Randy yeah she
slept with Randy Wow yes Wow is that
real yes really look it up man I swear
to god she in some interview wherever
it's out there what yeah Sharon slept
with Randy I think allegedly allegedly
yes yeah but I do believe it's in print
Wow oh yeah well I mean you know that
that's an interesting dynamic because
here they are out on this last saboteur
she is without bill man uh half oh look
here we can't even get into that yeah we
I know and ties just [ __ ] stupid I
know but uh uh she's the operator and
the manager and everything observe it
tour absolutely now he owns the name
yeah how is this gonna [ __ ] you know
just not self-destruct I really don't
know and they're supposed to play Oh
Hollywood ball yep and they're supposed
to play in New York somewhere Trey told
me I'm gonda which by the way you know
your lady had her in the podcast yeah
what a [ __ ] episode yeah dude that
was a good one man oh yeah that was a
good one oh man yeah she can talk that
one you know well I just watch it at
home I love her honesty yes and I love
the work that she's done and and just so
many people went back and started
rewatching Sopranos and emailing me over
the time going like holy [ __ ] the show I
think that show is going to find legs
again even in another generation from my
really do I really do I think people are
gonna go back to and say wow this was
great you know oh that you know people
have rewatched the series to three times
yeah it's gonna be all in the family
Sopranos and Breaking Bad Breaking Bad
yeah somebody mentioned to the wire and
I do i do a I do worship the wire I what
I like about it is it takes people a
long time to find the wire yeah and get
into it once they do they're like wow
what was it doing I feel like it got
better though it didn't come out strong
like say a breaking bad it's a creeper
it is a creeper absolutely man but it is
good it's a solid shot it's been going
on going on for a long time it's so
let's talk about your acupuncture
experience of mine I go in and I saw i'm
laying back i'm doing this stretching 45
yeah so i'm straight on a long bed and
then arms and neck just leaning down are
you so tired and and 45 minutes she said
she set a timer and man at two i was
like oh really what have you ever tried
that well dude I stretch in my life so
yes I do I gotta start as part of my
daily regimen in a sense it's really
funny because as you get older you
realize
you know modern medicine is just failing
me like I said with the handle in the
advils in the [ __ ] you know and you
start looking at this other [ __ ] and
she's like you need stretch five minute
morning you're five min at night she's
so rad I like this lady and I go yeah
okay so don't be skipping on it yeah and
it's true you start thinking about like
stretching you know like like I stretch
before I go on now up dude you'll see a
total transformation in your body over
like it over the course of say an entire
year five minutes and then you like you
up your increments a little because five
minutes after a while isn't gonna be in
the know what kind of stretching you
doing are you doing like the one where
you just leaned up put your palms to the
ground I do that one too yeah that's
closing your toes I can do that as a
good one you know on your back you know
your feet over your heads are going and
then try to try to straighten out your
hams you don't have to straighten your
legs out so you're getting a really good
ham stretch oh yeah yeah that's a good
one yeah I mean I stretch every time
before I guys let your hand yeah got
asked out of hands and the and the
shoulders and the biceps man cuz you
know I pinched nerves all the time no
dejan it's sucks so I got this what
you're going on here i can Steinman I
got this [ __ ] pinched nerve is going
down my neck here Yeah right over my
vocal cord oh now my vocal cords are
fine you know no problem but I didn't I
don't have strength when this flares up
because it's pressing it's right here
it's pressing over the Vogler and hurts
oh [ __ ] this part I'm like oh so I'm
like talking like it's like nuts to
butts ain't going it you know like a
like I can't give any strength yet
because then it's the neck muscles yeah
you know when you go don't you ever say
die your neck is all [ __ ] flesh and
stuff expanding so that expanded it's
like oh huh and once in a while I'm
getting this a lock to the right like I
just looked at right ah it's just stuck
there really yeah and then it'll come
come loose so I go in I've never done
acupuncture I'm not afraid of
needles in all look at me I'm covered in
tattoos what's there to be afraid of
she's like guys now that said the first
20 needles are so are fine all up my arm
around my ear oh yeah but when she gets
this one in the neck yeah that
[ __ ] smart huh then she starts
coming in like every 10 minutes and she
turns him Oh like turning in the screw
when they turn them yeah it's when it
[ __ ] you're like hey ya digg I turn
yours not yet no not no not yet man this
is why I'm in there I've only got one so
every 10 minutes she turns out i don't i
don't have that experienced oh I have a
kinder gentler Chinese dr. Ross so he
just poked in lees good guy um yeah he
he just pokes me and splits how long
were they in you um an hour right I go
no not even an hour well I think we I'm
like 30-40 minutes someone I minutes I'm
in there an hour you are ok yeah alright
you got it sounds to me like you got a
hardcore but it's good that's awesome
but not this this guy I may have to
check out where you're going to the
place that my lady is going to oh yeah
yeah she's going over there and so she
said won't you come along and they gave
me some Chinese are Chinese herbal tea
yeah i got like pellets all you did I
got the tea man it's like drinking you
know mark yeah it's like going out front
and just chewing on the front lawn
against it it's [ __ ] hardcore and
hers is even worse what's wrong with you
ladies she got a bad back or some or
something hurt no she doesn't but she
does actually have a you know some back
issues but that's not why she didn't rid
of stress well yes the lady told her
that she needed to do that today I'm
sorry Dre I'm signs I'm talking about
your doctor appointment this morning and
not my own but yeah the lady did tell
her she said you gotta you know yeah
let's dress yeah less stress but i'll
tell you the birthing of my place yeah
i'm in there and i'm enjoying just
laying down which by the way they close
it like [ __ ] 1130pm it morning oh you
gotta go
am oh my appointments are like 1130 in
the morning I couldn't do that well no
during the weekdays you're good yeah we
get a weekend okay okay so I'm in there
get there at nine thirty and I'm laying
in this room and there's another guy
next to me with the sheet down you know
oh and I got the pins in and I'm just
enjoying some serious [ __ ] like
meditations shut stands and hippie [ __ ]
yeah and I'll sitting to guys like so
comedian huh no and I look up but like
oh is this guy for real gonna [ __ ]
talk to me right now yeah yeah what kind
of stuff you do and I'm like uh yeah
just observational stuff you know yeah
yeah well uh like like a get run one for
me run and i said hey dude oh I'm
sleeping yeah wait wait how does he know
your community because the lady goes all
you stiff you Steve what do you do for
living and she said oh maybe I do
construction oh [ __ ] look I look like a
construction guy yeah we're motorcycle
repair man [ __ ] it man come on in it
looks like you need some new pistons and
rings to see so uh I so then I'm laying
there and the guy starts talking again
[ __ ] means motorcycle crash where'd that
happened like [ __ ] and I lose my [ __ ]
and I would stick him with pins yeah I
got pins in me I'm laying sideways and
also i'm laying on my right ear that's
my good one there so my left one doesn't
work very good so now not always he
talking it's through a [ __ ] curtain
and I can't even hear what he's saying
mmm so I'm gonna what yeah what and I
don't know why I'm answer him and I
realized he's just lonely in there cuz
you're in there for an hour but this
isn't where we talked to thats quiet
time never gonna see you again let's go
see I don't share rooms at my place yeah
I got my own private little energy
because it was a Saturday and they
popped me in that was fun I see but even
still they can occupy more than one
person in a room in this place I don't
think that they do do they play some
nice music in their fees no I need that
Oh see they they got it piped through
the hole
this is really cool Zen kind of yeah
waterfall monkey sounds and [ __ ] the
asian instruments yeah it's awesome yeah
some of this yeah that's good I will
fall asleep in one minute with the
[ __ ] I've been to hotels where they
got the rainmakers oh love this see you
later you know what every time I turn it
on though I keep waiting for right you
know I'm boys asleep once you coming
when does it come out yeah but yeah man
no I got a solo room and I'm happy for
it does he put a little red light by
your feet to keep your feet warm and
warm the needles now I'm up on my neck
and I'm up on my neck I said I think he
they what they do there's they use this
like heat lamp to actually heat the the
needles now what happened next was on
our needles yeah then they took the
needles out and then she did cupping did
you get that I've never been cuffed but
Dre has I see ya it was a monster
hickeys on my ass circles big song right
yeah man did that feel good did it feel
good oh well like they were pulling some
[ __ ] like you know some kind of not
out of here out of here man it was
awesome and then after the cupping some
weird red oil that she's rubbing into my
skin yeah yeah with a [ __ ] kind of a
rake really yeah strange stuff but uh
and then after that happy ending or this
like it's a complacent even wanted
you're just like I just got [ __ ]
needled he hopped [ __ ] red oiled talk
to a naked man next to me is what are
you going rate yeah no no i don't but
all men this is a funny thing it's so la
it's in koreatown yeah totally nice
place everything cool but in the lobby I
uh Trent Reznor come in he got bad neck
from [ __ ] you like an animal like she's
the Nine Inch Nails Sheikh Muhammad Ali
my grandma
she got all these cool people she worked
on yeah yeah yeah President Ford haha
man shoes she pulls amazing yeah yeah
Trent Reznor and they're so your lady
sounds like the list she's a hundred
years leprosy samples it's not really
well and uh seventy-five bucks for the
hour and a half you know I alright we
gotta talk because I got what you got we
gotta talk and they take insurance no I
don't have it but man your lady God if
you did m'lady does yeah she does she's
the only one that she's the only one
house won't you marry you're gonna
indicate if the kids have insurance but
you're gonna have it too when you get
married yeah you know I've gone so long
without it I don't know if I want it I
don't know like I don't know yeah you
keep that yeah yeah double down on
yourself I'm gonna be at a brutal and
I'm gonna be fine yeah no absolutely
it's I think it if most people at world
country in some places I think him
scenarios I think if people all people
were 21 yeah there was a mandatory you
just broke their leg at 21 and and they
got no insurance inning it's a right
when you're 21 we break your leg and you
have to just figure it out yeah yeah
many people would vote oh there's some
kind of [ __ ] healthcare zone I yeah
and not everybody's looking at me like
what about that Obamacare now man Obama
Shan ain't nobody taking that I got a
[ __ ] card in my pocket right now let
me show it to ya you know who will take
that los angeles county jail yeah
they'll probably they'll probably accept
that it's such a [ __ ] you go to your
dog can you go you go it's like a
business card that's not a proper card
is yeah here it is right yeah and [ __ ]
and then they go oh you gotta go to skid
row for that
really yeah and you you enter a tent
some some guys tent that's the car down
there and go like hey dude take care you
know I got some kind of a neck problem
they'd be like yeah well sir everyone
here yeah yeah you leave with more
issues you leave with stemi scurvy
dysentery what's that other one the one
from the water oh oh you get up you get
a [ __ ] I forget what it is hold on it
already honey yeah it'll come to ya
dirty water yeah that'll come to me ah
maybe a baby boot slipping my mind so uh
your record almost done it is it is it's
been recorded and mixed I went out to I
went out to New Jersey I went out to the
jurors with my friend and in grammy
award-winning mixer producer Warren
Riker yeah Riker he's uh he's awesome
and he's a good dude and uh yeah he he
he goes all out for me man this gives me
the bro rape fright no Franklin
Vanderbilt just said hey Franklin what's
up man we just did a gig in Vegas
together ya know how that game plant
would did anyone show up yeah they did
my god like down the street somebody was
playing it oh god always exact Motley
Crue's somebody was when you got Motley
Crue they're done whatever yeah snail
someone in that someone in that ya genre
but yeah I know but it was a good night
in a good time yeah we played a lot of
good tunes we'll do it again Franklin
ssin in New York what's up dude yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's yep huge fan nice
i'm a huge fan of his car he's got a
badass car for a dot yeah he'll send a
challenger yeah dude I thought I had him
on the show what a great guy he's out
playing with Lenny Kravitz yeah he's out
well I don't yeah he's something well
when it going to yeah I don't know if
it's official yet yeah he talked about
hoodie oh that's cool oh my go oh yeah
great all right guy he's a good dude
he's got great energy guy can play he's
a good yeah he can play duties a great
he's a [ __ ] hustler yeah yeah he is
he is well thanks for coming by today
dude dude thanks for having me come yeah
look before wouldn't you think the
records coming out well
that depends on you know who I decide to
you know do business will that's the
toughest part man it's like yep signing
your name on the dotted line I just kind
of really want somebody to just I just
kind of really think about what about
just doing a distribution deal or total
a stinking deal now that's Amelia
Whitesnake was going to go out and then
it got cancelled the Mexico dates they
got canceled now are you going out the
summits um I am yeah we start rehearsals
in like nine or ten days you should come
down a rehearsal one day do i wanna you
should come down think we could get
covered do a Whitesnake podcast and just
could we get him on it would you know we
could but it would have to be very like
the planet would not be good it would
have to be spur the moment i'll just
bring the equipment yeah cuz the planet
he it would be he'd be in a different
headspace yeah i know he would yeah you
know he would so well rehearsing at our
place we go to rehearsing at the usual
spot with a casual bud I gotta go over
there then yeah what we kick off yeah
man and um I gotta go there and meet
coverdale yeah so when is this it's um
in a couple of weeks you know yeah it's
in a couple by the way I'm doing seven
nights Edwin Rena start next tuesday no
at the lab factor can we get him to go
that would be [ __ ] awesome but I
don't know it's a tough one to get him
to go wait next Tuesday yeah yeah it's
tuesday through sunday next tuesday he
will still be in town I could I could a
squeeze do I could pass it along you
imagine if he came dude I never know hey
get me giving some day well my can
please say Dina not so sure i would like
to do your port cast but for another
time another time but wait you just got
in the rock and roll hall of fame well
yes ah yes i did tell me more tell me
more about mice yeah he's a wonderful
guy and you know what man they cut it
from his speech but he actually he
actually gave props to his band to us
really all us goofy bastards yeah man he
thought he i'd like to thank my bad
Wow stir red Beach and Joe Doakes turn
Michael Devon and Tommy Aldridge me but
they cut it from the TV slot but I
thought that was so thoughtful of him to
actually that's from that because he's
had a lot of cats in his band man he
doesn't need to be thanking us yeah you
know what I'm saying like now are you
very thoughtful he did that in the next
day you got like a pay decrease I give
you a shout out on somehow my my account
was minus tau yeah now um when's it to
start may be river may I think may wait
no I think our first official date is a
June first and I believe we are playing
in in Oklahoma dope so do no wrong mom
or whatever that not not the rocklahoma
thing now he doesn't really yeah he
doesn't usually go there it is a [ __ ]
out of that not really we do festivals
not really like we've done a couple of
festivals in the in the u.s. button the
festival's usually happen over in there
when are you playing here Europe you
know um we are playing here I don't know
there's you know I can't speak on it yet
but I heard through the grapevine that
uh we may come back through the States
after we go to Europe I heard that's a
possibility and then we will be hitting
this side of the country cuz we're not
so you're just doing some dates and then
go into year and then we hit Europe yeah
and then and then the talk is that we
will come back but i can't i can't say
that officially I can't confirm that you
guys play that give me all your love
tonight oh that one that's a staple whoa
yeah it's a staple edit great one and on
and on this tour it's a greatest hits
tour oh yeah man so it'll be a you know
with hands all love it yeah it was
blowing some dust off of some tunes what
once i can't i'm not gonna name it
because he will call me oh yeah Michael
what's the big idea he will I was home
listening here
yes that I will not be doing yeah yeah
by the way [ __ ] you and your job is in
castor now Michael you're fired no you
know it's a thing sometimes some things
are very yeah we keep things I don't
want to be the guy to spill the beans
that's all I'm gonna be on the other end
of that stick yeah and you know with
setlists he sometimes say stuff and then
it doesn't happen well if there are
certain songs that haven't been played
in a long time I think he wants to
excite and surprise his his fans that
have been tried and true for all these
years out you know and and I think
that's a good idea well I got it went
down and come down and watch the snake
rehearse get red Beach on the podcast oh
dude he would be he would be great on
this man he's got some great stories and
he's got no filter oh good he has no
philosopher who else in the band we've
got a Joel Hoekstra Oh what about the
drummer Tommy Aldridge get it when we
got him what about him can we get that
yeah that's harder than a three pick or
billy goat in here man he's got all
these different you possess homestead I
call him Tommy isms he's got a thousand
Tommy is we got to get that [ __ ] guy
on the podkayne it's colder than a horse
heart in here man whoa yeah yeah he's
tough yeah he's a tough one to bag bro
yeah yeah that's a tough that's a tough
interview to grab I've had the biggest
drummers in the world yeah be an ego
thing like hey well I had said to set
John yeah but Tommy is just he's just a
real private I think he's just a real
private guy right you know he's normal
dude man had some questions for him I
mean as abnormal as he I mean the only
where he is abnormal is in how his high
level of achievement on things like what
he's into he's into it like top two
percent of people like building his own
racing you know bikes oh yeah yeah
icicles yes man that guy like he builds
him from scratch and then sells them and
you know that's his that's everything
full on he can't like he because the
name of the company you know he doesn't
have it it's just Tommy Aldridge bikes I
rule cuz I'm Tommy Aldridge bodies dying
horse I dude I don't know like you gets
just a luck of the jar like he puts it
up on eBay wherever he does and you
from Tommy Aldridge and you don't even
know it I want that [ __ ] I want that guy
the podcast do but you know some of the
best frames you know in the world
they're not built in the US they built
in Italy in the courts in Germany and I
think Austria and they only build so
many pre I've learned a lot about bikes
because of Tommy I even went to the
plant with Tommy in a car engine Rev we
went to the to the point where they
manufacture this stuff and we spent the
day we rented Porsches well out on the
Autobahn really dude me a [ __ ] fly
and it was fun well I got a ticket right
you got a ticket yeah because there are
they care are zones yeah I didn't know
that right so my pitcher sends me this
photo of the ticket yeah and there's a
photo of my face and they get woman but
dude I have the biggest smile on my eyes
like it's like covered it I my first
time in audubon i flew into Germany and
I was uh going over there guns and roses
lenny kravitz black crowes faith no more
nice playing over there buddy picks me
up and his 7-series Beemer yeah zurich
switzerland patrick is his name you want
to go fast I remember he had the White
Zombie record in there yeah that one
song where the girl goes you want to try
me oh yeah and he just starts punching
it and I looked down we're doing a buck
70 and I said a did you know and he
looks of it you want to try min I'm like
this [ __ ] weirdo and while we're
doing 170 I hear this a [ __ ]
motorcycle went by us and all I heard
was the sound what we were doing 170 as
like and 170 after a while when he backs
down to like 125 you're like this is
normal yeah like your sunday driving
with Mehmet it's insane you going 125
but that [ __ ] bike went by and all I
heard was oh man dude you hit road on
that off that bike you have a buncha
nothing but ringing phone [ __ ] does
yeah yeah yeah that's it that's it dude
no
helmets gonna save your ass yeah nothing
nothing do I'll visual you want to try
me all right now let's get out thing all
right my grave your Twitter real quick I
Michael E Devin that is what I am yeah
Michael Devon on Instagram and Twitter
I'm on Instagram as Michael Lee Devon
yeah I'm on facebook yeah and I'm on a
month I'm on the Twitter and you're on
the base the Senators I am on the base
all summit i'm looking forward to and
also i can't wait whitesnake freaks out
to be it's gonna be a lot of fun I love
touring through the states in the summer
it's a best or bus no flights just
rolling all the summary to come on it's
the best of the summer ears bastard
you're just on there and your bunk like
be dozing off way to pop out of your
bunk coffee yeah no no yes see how the
band mate what's up dude yeah it's
what's [ __ ] great yeah life's good
like this still isn't nice oh wait I'm
going with play the whiskey tonight so
God tonight yeah I'm gonna play a few
songs out with her um well it's it's
that ultimate jam night what you start
with the yeah yeah yeahs bowling yeah I
know that yeah i'll be with matt star
yeah and uh and some of the cats Chuck
right place base something right I'm
gonna be playing with uh with matt and i
forget the guitar players name but yeah
i'm gonna do just a few songs what's a
good night it's free to get in yeah and
so come on down right at rock and roll
down that dude thanks for doing the show
today absolutely any time due to love it
love it here you go ok